c'est quoi ces gros machin c'est ma
maison
[Musique]
bon il y aura un escalier évidemment
voir une terrasse avec une porte
d'entrée par ici tu as les deux d'envoi
ou ouais ça c'est donc ma future maison
avec une autant d'ouvertures que
possible par rapport aux contraintes de
poids et c'est ce qui m'a décidé à vivre
là dedans c'est un peu un coup de coeur
pour ce petit habitat j'étais déjà dans
des choses pas très conventionnel pour
habiter j'ai vécu en camion une petite
année j'ai vécu dehors une partie de
l'année suivante dans un hamac en forêt
et donc je me cherchais un habitat qui
me corresponde vraiment qui me plaisent
qui me qui m'enthousiasme en fait est
une maison ça me fait pas tellement
rêver c'est ça me paraît lourd ça me
fait un peu peur c'est du ménage c'est
l'entretien c'est des taxes et sur un
mode de vie complètement alternatifs ont
été exécutées dans un programme à 40 et
ostéo c'est un choix dit c'est vraiment
un choix j'ai vraiment la possibilité de
faire autrement c'est clair ça serait
d'ailleurs certainement plus simple mais
ça me plairait un petit peu moins et oui
je suis ostéo je travaille tous les
jours je vais au boulot comme tout le
monde ça se voit pas de l'extérieur que
je
vit dans des conditions un peu
particulières et j'y tiens beaucoup
c'est important pour moi de garder
vraiment un ancrage à l'intérieur de la
société d'être avec les gens ne pas être
marginalisés en fait là je sens qu'on va
le faire en première
[Musique]
et cet aspect ça fait surtout partie
d'un confort en réalité parce que je
trouve ça important d'avoir enfin moi
l'écologie je trouve que c'est juste
essentiel aujourd'hui
par contre je veux en aucun cas être
dans la frustration parce que si c'est
pour après commencé à trouver que tout
le monde devrait faire comme moi ou
autre c'est la lola aussi c'est pas mon
rayon mais je me rends compte que moi je
me sens bien quand je suis dans quelque
chose qui avec lequel je suis d'accord
complètement et ça ça passe aussi par ne
pas abîmer ce qui est autour de moi
autant que possible alors celle-ci avec
l'autonomie et tous les systèmes un
petit peu clé en main parce que moi je
ne sais pas planter un clou et je fais
plutôt confiance atteler lignum pour
cela je vais payer 70 milles à priori
c'est ce qui est prévu à être belle je
l'attends comme j'ai jamais attendu
autre chose moi qui adore dormir dehors
c'est quelque chose tellement important
j'espère que cette nuit là je pourrais
ouvrir mon toit et eux mettre dans mon
lit à la belle étoile
puis bon sinon il y aura au moins la
vitre le bruit de la pluie
c'est des choses que j'adore le bruit de
la pluie sur la vitre le vent qui fait
légèrement bouger une taille ni ça bouge
un peu ce pas comme une maison fixa
aussi j'attends c'est des sensations que
j'ai appris à adorer en fait
en fait on voit tout dit tout haut on
voit tout c'est génial ouais ça fait une
ça fait une brève eu un on se rend pas
compte en prenant si peu de hauteur mais
c'est déjà excellent je pense que je
ferai des apéros sur mon lit
[Musique]